[Music]
Well, hello dear friends. Welcome to the
program. I'd like to know, we've been
getting an awful lot of questions in
recent days. Uh we only do a half an
hour every week, so maybe we're going to
have to expand this
uh because we have so many questions and
uh we don't have enough time to answer
them all.
Uh but we have a really interesting
question today. I have with me uh
brother my dear friend uh brother Af
Rafferty James Rafferty. James the
lesser. No, not the lesser.
Um and you know he's done programs with
us before
but uh he was kind of unofficial at that
time
but starting Monday
yesterday.
Yesterday
yesterday
he is officially
uh working here at Secrets Unsealed.
Yeah.
And we're glad that you are. I'm glad to
be here.
And his wife Reissi is with us, too. And
she's going to be doing programming as
well.
Amen.
We're glad that you accepted the
Macedonian call.
I'm glad that God led us here. We're
praising the Lord.
Amen. Uh so anyway, uh we have some very
interesting questions. I want to just uh
provide the address. If you want to send
us questions, uh you can do it to the
following address. TV tvsumtv.org.
Once again, tvsumtv.org.
org. Uh just send us your questions. You
know, we might have to add a half an
hour or an hour to answer all the
questions that we have, but uh we'll
take a look at that and uh we want to
have a word of prayer to begin
then I'll frame the question and then
we'll get into the discussion.
Sounds good.
So James, would you pray for us please?
Sure. Be happy. Father in heaven, we
just want to thank you again for each of
the viewers and for this question that's
come in, this honest question that's
come in about Passover and how that how
that relates to the Bible verses, the
texts that describe that event in the
life of Christ in the Gospels. We want
to pray for your spirit to lead and
guide the conversation and that our
hearts will be in tune with heaven and
that this question will be answered in a
way that's in harmony with your word. So
guide us to this end. We pray in Jesus
name. Amen. Jesus name. Amen. Praise the
Lord. Okay. Uh when we discuss this
question, probably I'll just read the
question first and then I'll make a
couple of comments as to what is
non-negotiable when we try to answer
this question. Um here's the question. I
was listening to the Hebrew calendar
series some time ago. That's a series
that I did for anchor two or three years
ago.
Okay.
Uh and this this is the continuation of
the question. John 13:1
shows how Jesus did not keep the
Passover on its actual day.
How do we explain Luke 22:7, Mark 14:12,
Matthew 26:17,
which show probably Jesus kept the
Passover on the exact day.
So John seems to say not on the exact
day.
Uh and the other reference is that Jesus
actually kept it on the exact day.
Okay. So, um, let me just mention two
things that are not negotiable when we
deal with this. And that is in Leviticus
23, we're told that the Passover was
celebrated on the 14th of Nissan.
Okay?
Has nothing to do with the automobile,
by the way.
Uh, the 15th of Nissan, the very next
day, uh, you have the feast of unleven
bread. Okay? Which lasted a period of
seven days and then an eighth day was
tacked on later. Then you have uh Nissan
uh which would be uh represent the
resurrection of Christ which is the u
waving of the sheath
sheath. Okay.
So so 14 15 and 16 of Nissa are Nissan
are the first three Hebrew feasts.
Okay.
Um now the question is what days of the
week did those fall uh when Jesus
actually was on this earth?
Okay. And uh the bottom line is it's
very clear that they were fulfilled.
Passover, unleaven bread, and first
fruits were uh fulfilled on Friday,
Sabbath, and Sunday.
Okay.
So, I want to read a statement from
Ellen White, which is absolutely clear
because there are some that say that
Jesus actually died on a Wednesday,
right?
And resurrected on Sabbath. I've heard
that. And there's somebody else um who
said that he actually the three days and
three nights begins on Tuesday when um
Judas made the agreement with the
religious leaders to betray him for the
30 pieces of silver
and that Jesus then resurrected on
Friday right at sundown.
Oh.
So um those obviously and they're
Adventists too. So
uh but Ellen White makes it very clear
in this article, The Man of Sorrows,
February 24, 1898. It's actually
manuscript 251 1898. Uh she wrote, "The
father and the son rested after their
work of creation. Thus the heavens and
the earth were finished and all the host
of them. And on the seventh day God
ended his work which he had made and God
blessed the seventh day and sanctified
it because that in it he had rested."
And then she comments, she's quoting
Genesis 2 1:3. Mhm.
Uh the death of Christ was designed to
be at the very time in which it took
place. It was in God's plan that the
work which Christ had the work in which
Christ had engaged to do should be
completed on a Friday
and that on the Sabbath he should rest
in the tomb.
Even as the father and the son had
rested after completing their creative
work.
Isn't that interesting?
Clearly Ellen White says that Jesus
actually died. He completed his work
said it is finished on the cross on
Friday
and on Sabbath he rested in the tomb
which means that he would have
resurrected on Sunday
and that is so interesting because that
phrase it is finished that's the word
that Christ used those that was the
phrase that Christ used when he died and
it was the same phrase that was used in
Genesis and both of those phrases were
were used on Friday.
Absolutely. That would be Genesis
chapter 2 and verse one I think.
Okay. uh where it says um Genesis 2
verse one uh let's see it says uh after
verse 31 actually chapter 2 and verse
one belongs to chapter 1.
Yeah
it should be the conclusion to chapter 1
the chapter division is in the wrong
place but it says then God saw
everything that he had made and indeed
it was very good. So the evening and the
morning were the sixth day. Thus the
heavens and the earth and all the host
of them were finished.
Okay. So there you have clearly the word
finished on the sixth day.
And then of course verses two and three
refer to him ceasing from his work on
the seventh day.
And you've got the same phrase in John
chap 19 and verse 30 where when Jesus
therefore had received the vinegar he
said it is finished and he bowed his
head and gave up the ghost
very clearly.
And then after he after he finished in
Genesis, he rested.
After he finished on the cross,
he rested.
He rested. Yes.
The whole day in the tomb.
Yes.
And his followers rested outside.
That is powerful.
So anyway, how do we resolve this issue
of u the seeming discrepancy between uh
the synoptic gospel writers and the
gospel of John? I like the fact that you
bring this up that it's a seeming
discrepancy because I think that's uh
really important for us as we start any
kind of investigation. We need to
recognize that the word of God is
inspired but the humanity of you know
human beings comes into it all and blurs
it sometimes and we really need to look
into this and investigate it. Many times
it's not really the word of God that's a
problem. It's the way it's written or
how we perceive it or how it's
translated. you know, various
translations can sometimes cause
difficulty. And so, there's a seeming
contradiction, but when we unearth all
of the evidence, we're going to find
that everything comes together
beautifully in the word of God, all
inspired. Now, there's something that is
very clear, and that is that Jesus died
as a as the Passover lamb
about 3:00 in the afternoon on Friday.
Which means that when he told his
disciples to prepare the Passover
on the day before
on Thursday evening,
uh that was actually uh that occurred
before the Passover.
Yeah. before the actual Passover,
before the actual Passover,
right?
And so the question is, why would Jesus
celebrate the Passover
before the fulfillment on on Friday
afternoon at 3:00 in the afternoon? Why
would he do that?
Yeah. I I I you know, it's interesting
because Paul says that Christ, our
Passover, is sacrificed for us. So Jesus
knew that he was going to be the
fulfillment of this thing. this this
thing was going to end and he was going
to be the fulfillment of it the next
day.
So, one of the reasons why we we know
that Christ did this was because he was
transitioning his church, his new
Christian church from the Passover, from
the sacrifices, from that whole system
of ceremonial law, he was transitioning
into a whole new system that met its
fulfillment in him. And so he was
putting in place of the Passover the
Lord's supper.
So now that believers who follow Christ
and really we don't throw out the Old
Testament. A lot of New Testament
Christians throw out the Old Testament.
We don't throw out the Old Testament. We
see the types in the shadows as
meaningful for us even in the New
Testament in in the the dispensation
that we're in because we are in a second
dispensation in a sense. But we
recognize that Christ takes those types
and shadows, fulfills them, and in some
instances puts something else in their
place. And Thursday night, he was doing
that.
Yeah. And of course, there's a practical
reason why Jesus celebrated the Passover
in advance. And it is
that he certainly could not institute
communion when he was hanging on the
cross, right, on Friday,
right? So there's a practical reason why
Jesus actually uh you know instituted
the Lord's supper to replace the
Passover on Thursday evening instead of
and by the way he did fulfill
the the symbolism of the Passover
literally
on Friday afternoon at 3:00.
So he did die as the Passover lamb, the
fulfillment of the Passover lamb on
Friday afternoon. But what he celebrated
on Thursday night with the disciples was
the announcement of what was going to
happen the very next day because
isn't that something
he had to institute it on Thursday
because he couldn't do it in practical
terms on on Friday. Yeah. When he was
hanging on the cross,
it was going to be impossible.
Yeah.
Yeah. Good point.
So So let's read uh here uh Exodus 12.
Okay.
And verses 5 and six. and uh give this
uh some biblical foundation what we're
talking about.
Uh Exodus 125 and 6 gives us a specific
day
and hour
when the Passover was supposed to be
celebrated.
All right. Exodus 125 and 6.
Yeah. When the Passover was actually the
Passover lamb was to be killed.
Okay. Your lamb, Exodus 12:5, your lamb
shall be without blemish, a male of the
first year. Ye shall take it out from
the sheep or from the goats. Verse six,
and ye shall keep it up until the 14th
day of the same month. Then the whole
assembly of the congregation of Israel
shall kill it in the evening. So you
take it out and then you keep it until
the 14th day of the same month.
So it's four days before.
Okay.
And then it's then it's brought.
Uh you know, and sacrificed.
Okay.
Um there there's something really
interesting. Uh I think are you reading
from the King James version?
I am.
The King James version says they shall
kill it at evening.
But literally in Hebrew this is this is
not the usual. Literally in Hebrew it
says you shall kill it between the two
evenings.
Yeah. In the margin here it says from
the 9th to the 11th hour.
That's what the margin in my King James
says. From the 9th to the 11th hour.
Yeah.
Between the two evenings. That's what
the
Yeah.
Okay. Let let me just read a statement
from Adam Clark's commentary. Okay, I
love these old commentaries because
they're really focused on scripture. You
know, Barnes and Adam Clark among
others.
Clark is great.
Um, so he's explaining what between the
two evenings means because that's what
it says really in it says in the Hebrew.
Okay.
U, the Jews divided the day into morning
and evening
till the sun passed the meridian that is
at noon.
Mhm. All was morning or for noon.
After that, all was afternoon or
evening.
So at noon, what's before that is
morning. What's after that is evening.
Okay.
Uh and then he continues, the first
evening began just after 12:00 and
continued till sunset.
The second evening began at sunset and
continued till night during the whole
time of twilight between 12:00 therefore
and the termination of twilight the
Passover was to be offered. So so Jesus
was offered at the 9inth hour
which in in our way of reckoning time
would be at 3:00 in the afternoon.
Gotcha. So between the two evenings
would mean between noon when the sun
begins its descent
and sundown when the sun
sets
sets. Mhm.
And between those two times of course is
3:00 in the afternoon.
Wow.
And um
which is the ninth hour
which is the ninth hour according to the
margin.
The margin says 9th to the 11th hour.
Yes.
Yeah. So, so basically Jesus died around
three o'clock in the afternoon
and uh and of course after that
um there were several things that had to
take place you know they had to um
Joseph of Arythea had to go and ask for
the body of Jesus and ask Pilate.
Then Jesus had to be taken down from the
cross. He had to be transported to the
to the tomb.
Uh you know then they had to uh they had
to wash his body and they had to wrap
him in linen. They had to roll the
stone, you know, and then his followers
had to quickly go home
uh so that they would be home by the
time the Sabbath began. That would have
taken the better part of three hours,
right?
And then when the sun sets, then begins
the feast of unleven bread,
which because it it begin the 15th of
Nissan begins at sundown.
Okay?
And so then they partake of the Passover
lamb that was killed. And they um not
only partake of the Passover lamb, but
they partake also of of uh unleaven
bread. Oh,
okay.
So, that would be the 15th of Nissan,
the beginning of the feast of unleaven
bread,
right?
But that still has to do with the
Passover because they're eating the
Passover lamb along with the unleven
bread
which was slain the night before, the
day before, the evening before,
right?
Okay.
Huh. So, so um you know maybe we can
also look at what the Apostle Paul's
record
okay
um of uh the communion service 1
Corinthians 11 23- 26
uh 1 Corinthians 11:23-26.
All right. 1 Corinthians 11 beginning
with verse 23.
For I have received of the Lord that
which also I delivered unto you, that
the Lord Jesus the same night in which
he was betrayed, took bread, and when he
had given thanks, he broke it and said,
"Take, eat. This is my body which is
broken for you. This do in remembrance
of me." After the same manner also he
took the cup when he had sucked, saying,
"This cup is the new testament in my
blood. This do ye as often as you drink
it in remembrance of me. For as often as
you eat this bread and drink this cup,
you do show the Lord's death till he
come.
So this is happening on Thursday night.
Okay.
And Jesus is saying
this bread
represents my broken body,
right?
Which wasn't taking place at that time,
The next day,
right?
And he's saying uh the grape juice, this
is my blood
of the new covenant. Mhm.
Although he hadn't shed his blood yet,
it was going to be shed the next day.
Wow.
Uh so
brings a lot more meaning to it to the
to the service what he was pointing
forward to. It it seems to me that the
disciples didn't get that.
They're they are there and they don't
get that. But afterwards they must have
just exploded with you know
understanding of what Christ was
actually doing when he uh instituted the
last supper.
Yeah.
He was looking forward. They they
weren't seeing it because they weren't
expecting him to be crucified, but he
was looking forward to what was about to
take place on that next uh day and they
weren't they weren't seeing it.
Yeah. One Bible study that I would have
liked to have been present for
is the one that Jesus gave to the
disciples on the road to Emis followers.
Not the
had heartburn. You would have need some
roates for that one. I think in fact,
let's let's turn there. Luke chapter 24.
Uh Luke chapter 24.
Um and um you know we'll begin reading
at uh verse 25 through verse 27
u you know where Jesus actually uh
catches up to them and starts walking
with them.
All right Luke 23 beginning with verse
25 and let's read through verse 27.
And he released oh excuse me that's the
wrong one. Luke 20
25 to 27. And when he had found when
they found not his body, they came
saying that they had also seen a vision
of angels, which said that he was alive.
And certain of them which were with
which and certain of them which were
with us went to the supplr and found it,
even so, as the women had said, but him
they saw not. Then he said unto them,
"Oh fools, and slow of heart to believe
all that the prophets have spoken." So
this is this is Jesus walking with the
two disciples and the two disciples are
explaining to him and they think he's a
stranger. They don't know it's Christ.
They're explaining to him what actually
happened from their perspective. You
know, they went to the to the tomb and
the body wasn't there. And because the
women had already come to them and told
them the body was gone and so they went
to check it out and then they saw a
vision of angels which said that he was
alive.
And then Jesus takes over in verse 25
and says, you know, you are so slow to
understand everything that's been spoken
in the prophets. They understood they
understood some of it.
They just didn't understood all of it.
They understood some of it, you know,
because they knew that Christ was
Messiah. They believed he was the
Messiah.
Yeah. Sure.
But there was other parts of it that
they were confused about because they
had been taught the Messiah was going to
come to conquer the Romans, not to die
on a cross.
Yeah. In verse 27 it says, "And
beginning at Moses,
that's the Torah,
"And all the prophets, the Nebim,
and in all the scriptures, the Kthubim,
the three divisions of the Old Testament
in the times of Christ."
Okay?
So, in other words, he's going through
all of the scriptures.
Okay?
So, it says, "And beginning at Moses and
all the prophets, he expounded to them
in all the scriptures the things
concerning himself."
Now, I would have liked to have known
which passages from the Old Testament
Jesus used.
Oh, he must have at least started with
Genesis 3:15, right?
Yeah, probably.
Isaiah Isaiah 53.
Yeah. Isaiah 53.
Psalm 22. My God, my God, why have you
forsaken me?
The Hebrew festivals. Yeah. At least the
first three of them.
All of them. Yeah. Um I think Yeah.
Hosea 6 also. It talks about
the three days.
Yes. After three days. Yeah. and Jonah.
The story of Jonah,
of course.
Yeah,
that would have been an exciting Bible
study.
I would have really liked to have been
there.
I wonder if the Holy Spirit speaks to us
even today as we walk with Christ, if
the Holy Spirit points us to some of the
very same scriptures that Christ pointed
them to when he walked with them on the
road to Emmas. Because aren't there
times when our hearts just burn with
this picture of Christ in the Old
Testament? I mean, a lot of us as
Christians, we believe the New Testament
is like the most important part of the
Bible, but I don't think so. Not that
the Old Testament is more important, but
I think that the Old and the New
Testament are one.
And we can see that right here because
Jesus, as recorded by Luke in the New
Testament, is focusing on the Old
Testament. And he's saying that all all
of the Old Testament talks about me.
Yeah. What's more important, the root or
the tree? M
well without the root there is no tree
but if there's no tree there's no reason
for a root.
The Old Testament is the root.
It's the root of everything in the New
Testament
and the New Testament so to speak is the
tree.
Yes.
So they have to go together.
They have to. And unfortunately in the
Christian world uh the Old Testament to
a great degree has been depreciated as
being old covenant you know um
emphasizing law and not grace. Uh it's
been kind of demeaned
but the Old Testament has law and grace.
It does
not only gra not only law but also
grace.
It's filled with grace.
So let's go to chapter 24. Uh being that
we're talking about uh the Bible study
that Jesus gave to the disciples, he
also gave a Bible study later to the
disciples in the upper room.
Yes,
I would have liked to have been there
too.
Uh Luke 24
Luke chapter 24 and verse 44- 47 if you
want to read those.
Okay. Luke 24:44. And he said unto them,
"These are the words which I spake unto
you while I was yet with you, that all
things must be fulfilled, which were
written in the law of Moses, and in the
prophets, and in the Psalms concerning
me." Then opened he their understanding
that they might understand the
scriptures,
and said unto them, Thus it is written,
and thus it behooved Christ to suffer,
and to rise from the dead the third day,
and that repentance and remission of sin
should be preached in his name among all
nations, beginning at Jerusalem. And ye
are witnesses of all these things.
And then he speaks about Pentecost. Mhm.
In verse 49, it says, "Behold, I send
the promise of the my father upon you,
but tear in the city of Jerusalem until
you are endowed
with power from on high." So basically
what he's doing here is he's talking
about the fulfillment of of the first
four feasts.
Wow.
His death,
burial, resurrection,
and the outpouring of the Holy Spirit on
the day of Pentecost.
Wow.
plus many plus undoubtedly he was
referring to many other passages from
the Old Testament.
Yeah, I've got a few here. Zechariah
chapter 10 and Zechariah 12
and Hosea 6 1-3 because Hosea 6 talks
about the reign, the former and the
latter reign. And of course, we know
that that the apostles received the
former reign on the in the outpoint of
the pen of the spirit on Pentecost and
we are to be waiting for that latter
reign
that's to come. You know, it kind of
kind of reminds me of the parallel of
the great disappointment in 1844.
You know, very very similar. They had
prophecy. Yeah. They it's the last part
of the prophecy. And you know, the
Millerites, they longed for the coming
of Christ.
You know, they they left their potatoes
in the field. They sold all their
belongings. Sometimes they interceded
for their relatives all night in prayer.
you know, they paid the debts of
individuals so that they wouldn't be uh
indebted when Jesus came. And then, you
know, October 22, 1844, their,
you know, their faith was severely
tried.
Yeah.
Um, were there prophecies that pointed
to what was going to happen October 22,
1844?
Yes.
Bunches of prophecies,
but they misunderstood them.
So, the problem was not with God. The
problem was with the understanding of
the individuals.
Absolutely. And we do that all the time.
You know, we h we have assumptions that
we bring to the Bible. So, one
assumption they had was that the earth
was the sanctuary. Well, you don't
really find that in scripture.
So, when they went back to study what
the sanctuary really was, they
discovered, oh, the sanctuary isn't the
earth. You know, so you come to the
Bible with certain assumptions and it's
it's very easy for our minds to read
into scripture something that isn't
there because we have an assumption. We
have an idea that we want to support.
And so we're looking to read scripture
in a certain way.
Nowhere in scripture does it say that
the earth is the sanctuary. There's not
one single verse that says that the
earth is the sanctuary
that needed to be cleansed. But
they longed for the coming of Jesus so
intensely
that uh you know they wanted him
actually to come as king of kings and
lord of lords just like the disciples
did you know they expected him to take
over the kingdom of glory
but there were certain things that
needed to happen before that
and I think we're doing the same thing
today you know with Sabbath there's no
way in the Bible I mean when I first I
was raised Catholic when I first was
confronted with the idea of going to
church on Saturday I thought that's
ridiculous the Bible teaches Sunday but
there's no way in the Bible that
actually teaches that
right
but I thought it did you know and that
was an assumption you know just like
sanctuary being the earth was an
assumption right
and we assumed that primarily because in
the religious world then everyone
believed that the earth was the
sanctuary and everyone believes today
that Sunday is the seventh day it's the
Sabbath it's the Lord's day right
but it's not in the Bible
so it's a no-brainer right
it's yeah it should be
well let's just summarize what we've
studied uh Jesus instituted the Lord's
supper Mhm.
on Thursday evening
which would actually be Friday.
Friday.
We call it Thursday evening.
So even there you have some you know
good-
which was which was actually the day of
Passover the 14th
it was the day of Passover you know
technically
and and so he did that because for
practical reasons you know he couldn't
institute the Lord's supper while he was
hanging on the cross
but the institution of communion
actually pointed forward to what was
going to happen the next day.
Yes. And so Jesus then dies around 3:00
in the afternoon between the two
evenings.
And uh you know then he he's prepared
for burial
and then when he's in the tomb resting
and all of the other followers are in
their homes
then they gather together and they
partake of the Passover lamb and they
partake of the unleaven bread. And so
the the feast of unleaven bread begins
after sundown on the 15th of
Nissan. And really, you have that whole
event transpiring in fulfillment. It's a
perfect fulfillment of what Christ came
to do. That's why Paul calls Christ our
Passover lamb was slain for us.
Well, thanks for folks for being with
us. Our time is up. God bless you. Hope
to see you next time.
[Music]